Thank You Jared Thank You Jerry for
having me thanks for the venue for being
available to housed us here I'd like to
do this in interactive things so on the
anumita page there is a non link
unfortunately but I think Jarrod has
posted a comment yeah well this is this
is a proper link will take you to the
documentation page
you throw right to the bottom that's the
important stuff that you see there the
life setting the life cycle badge which
means we're not going to change the APA
the API that much anymore it's kind of
ready to use we think we need to work on
these Travis builds and what I really
like is this our student club button
which when you click will take you to an
our studio instance with everything
installed ready to go
except for the database which I don't
think is available on to the cloud
I'm going to go through this script and
I see dot R and if you have any
questions or anything is unclear just
feel free to interrupt
it's better thank you let's go this is
my local session it's this legible
it's just large enough maybe try
something longer should I switch to
black and white or is this good enough
okay thank you
so the lesson that relational animals in
our what is this all about let's start
with a small poll who's using deep flyer
and other tattooers packages for data
manipulation but a few that's great
who's using DB flyer which is which is
deep flower accessing a database awesome
so in general who has worked with
databases I I'm going to see all hands
up here thank you
so on the other side of the spectrum who
has worked with the software where you
load the data set and work the data set
unfortunately I don't have enough SPSS
experience but this is what it felt like
when it when using this and yeah anyway
in our are using more than one data
frame at the same time occasionally so
yeah there is this slight imbalance on
the other hand we want the dataset on
the other hand we really enjoy working
with multiple tables why's that
so I've been reading this few times now
this is the data we're going to look at
today a diagram the boxes are tables the
text in the boxes or cone names so the
underlined column names carrier Calum
and so what our primary keys means they
uniquely identify rows in the table the
arrows are foreign keys so the arrow
from the carry : flights to the Airlines
means that the values in this column map
to values in that other table in all
brevity if you haven't used this before
formally speaking primary key means
there are no duplicates in this in this
curriculum across the entire table
foreign keys means for all values in the
rule payable there is a matching value
in the orange table so for modeling for
visualization really all we want is a
single table that's fair enough
or to combine multiple tables there is
to join or the merge operation I'm going
to do this with the flight's table and
be in the elements table and I use
select to rearrange so the main column
comes from the LS table and we see the
name and the carrier's matching and
their repeated values nothing new um
this is a plotting example so if we
wanted to do this control
it out works great
maybe I'm I was pushing the button
that's possible too that should be on
there now it's all there you okay yeah
so
this fall showing how many flies in each
month for each airline with a full name
of the airline and not the abbreviation
and this is combining multiple tables
will also appear in modeling if you want
to build a model for flight delay based
on I don't know weather data and maybe
the airplane type and whatnot so this is
the join expression that will bring it
all in it will give you all the all the
related tables into one large wide table
so you can start working with it now we
go to stop right here so that's good
we're ready to model except when we
really start looking into the data we
see oh we don't have let it heat
longitude values for all all the flights
what happened so the John wasn't perfect
probably and we see so so the horn keys
don't match here and there's a whole
array of problems that that occurs with
with joining merging data that I'm not
going to talk about in detail there's a
fairly large appendix in the script
pretty sure you have seen all of them at
least once no
probably many times
so
drugs are tricky but keeping information
localized in as the single source of
truth has its advantages so this is
again the drawn with the between fights
and and alliance we need to update the
airline stay the Ellen stable only want
some of the elements table to correct
information that will then when joining
again propagate to all the rows so I
think we really want to work as long as
possible in the normalized data model
and join only when doing the
visualization the modeling part and this
is what the M helps to do so it's a
package available in github and you can
load it and when you print it it will
tell you where the tables live so these
are local tables it also works against
databases it will tell you the table
names number of columns and it will tell
you about the relationships so if only
this this behaves like a list of tables
like a named list of tables you can use
the dollar operator P you can create the
names of the tables if only for this I
think this is already useful because
yeah I have a [ __ ] of things going on
here but this if I rerun in a clean
session it's only this one object I see
in my environment and this object
contains all the tables right so this is
the implies it's a large TM in this case
and so it's contains or maybe not a copy
of all tables but put a reference to all
tables so tables with the metadata
and the contents together the primary
and foreign keys are a DM object so
we've seen the visual so I see three
principal use cases for this and I'd
like to I like this also to be my
take-home message kind of today so first
use case somebody has prepared a DM
object for you and you can work with it
as a user you can reorganize we we
combine flatten for for analysis or
realization and so forth doesn't need to
be in our function we can also connect
to databases and learn this the schema
from the database in some cases so the
second use cases imagine you're getting
a less than clean data set and to clean
it up you want to work in the normalized
schema you want to decompose tables you
want to have single source of truth for
for all the information that your data
brings you can even without assistance
from your IT department that take
forever to set up a database for you
build a data model with in memory data
frames or perhaps against the sequel eye
database that works on your machine you
don't need help with the setup and the
third use case you have prepared the
data set that's really clean that's
really checked and you want to make it
useful for others so then deploying such
a DM object to a database is only a few
steps it's
see how to connect with existing data so
the the M package has a function that
gives you a pre-built data model that's
what I'm using in all these examples you
can start using it right away
selecting tables in this case we don't
need to work with the weather data just
yet we use select table to remove a
table we use the M select to select
specific columns in one of these tables
we're on this the result has fewer
columns same number of tables and so
forth now I think the exciting thing
about this this also works against the
database I have a set of a small
Postgres database with a flights data in
one of the schemas or Hawaii si
I have the client seems seems hung here
they're showing you this but this is the
Postgres
they reverse error on my machine same
tables same relationships load it from
the database loaded from information
from metadata specified in a database
and we can proceed removing more columns
from the tables we don't need maybe we
want to select or we were only
interested for a subset of rows in the
tables and and also the related tables
so this is what filter will do for you
we're on this and the filters are
available as a the filter expressions
are are printed as part of the object so
this is useful for defining your new
data set that you worked with not not as
a big wide table but as a composition of
multiple tables where the the columns
you use and the rows you keep are
visible maybe at the beginning of your
script and you compose the data model
object and show look this is the data
we'll be looking at in this I've been
I've been growing the pipe here and this
this has a reason so none of this
persists unless we store this as an as
an or object so I've done all these
things but the DTM flights still has all
the the original information we need
just like in deep flier DB player we
need to store the results as a as a new
object to make this available for
two computations this is what I do here
and it's there it's the reduced number
of columns working you can see database
and I also can draw it the colors are
gum because this is learn from the
database in the built-in thing I have
pretty colors also how do you do colors
later
so the flights in this object are
because this is against the database are
lazy tables we see when we print them
it's lazy query under the hood the
sequel that generates the data is a bit
more complicated it's it's hidden in
these filters and the application of the
filter across the relationships so I
think that's that's easier it and
compose into trance manually collect
like what supplier will bring in the
data to your local machine so that it
becomes a DM object of data frames same
thing just the sources change
okay
so that's the setup once we have defined
our columns selected our tables build it
the rows we can start working with it
and so the join is one of the principal
operations one sub from scratch here and
join two tables so I'm joining airlines
and flights here so we have to find the
joints to go from left to right in the
arrow direction so it's in this case
flights then airlines and there is no
need to specify the column to join by
it's the regimental knows what the
relationships are again you can forget
about them it just works joining many
tables I remember tweeted early last
week how how do I join multiple tables
that's how I do it this was the join
from the very beginning where I bring in
all of tables that are related to the
flights table as one flat table based on
what the relationships are defined this
is our strategy for emigration so as
soon as we have the same column name
more than once across multiple tables we
rename we prefix the resulting column
name with the table name which in this
example exit immediately clear that this
is the year come from the flights table
to get rid of this message we can remove
columns or rename columns beforehand
which is good practice the
disambiguation logic is also accessible
separately with this here's a b-grade
calls
function in this case origin was used
more than once across the data model and
this means the foreign key is renamed
but the relationships still space well
defined because we try to come in
everything so one of the features I'm
really excited about this heady
manipulation in DM so our tag to this
and this was a discussion with Thomas
Lynn Peterson who had a similar
experience in this tidy graft package so
we decided to follow his approach and we
find data manipulation is a three-step
process you zoom into a table then you
can use the flyer manipulation tidier
manipulation to manipulate the data in
the table and then we put it back either
we override the table or we store this
as a new table in the same data model so
this is what it looks like when we use
it
zooming gives us something that looks
like a table feels like a table it's not
a table it's an object that that we have
under under control that that will
implement all of no that's much well
implement many deep liar verbs for sure
the most important ones and track what
happens to the data and what happens to
the column names so that we can adjust
the relationships so this example adds a
column am/pm depending on the departure
time if it's I am p.m. we have a new
column here
and it's still just a zoom table so to
have two results back in the data model
we update let's repeal
that's one more column and again as a
reminder immutable objects means nothing
persists unless we store this as a new
variable in the or or as a as a new
object in the in the our environment
this is an example for a summary I'm
using count which there's a group I
summarized for them of rows and I'm
inserting this as a new table into my
object and the new table becomes
connected to the existing table because
the summary used one of the foreign keys
and the foreign key was still available
after we can be to the summary so we
know that the relationship is valid it
is retained from you who put it back so
this in all brevity I'm not sure yet
where this is going but I think these
these basic building blocks being able
to use data manipulation inside such a
data model object allow for much richer
verbs that that will tell you which rows
don't have a matching row in the related
table what are the values of the keys
they don't match where you have other
problems in the data so we can use this
as basic infrastructure to build
tools that that that help us clean such
relation the item loves so that we can
have a better time when when fertilizing
and modeling this this later
that's for users now you think okay I I
don't have a DM object yet and I also
don't have a data buy it a database and
said I have this pile of Excel files
what I do so creating a DM object is
fairly easy like constructor is making
the table constructor you give the table
objects you want to insert as arguments
and this is what you get in the result
if we draw this so there are no
relationships yet this will be pretty
boring the relationships are added with
two verbs at PK and at FK @ p key will
define primary keys that's the first
thing to do this will give us the
underlined column names add F key will
add a foreign keys that's the arrows we
do this and we've something that very
much resembles what we saw throughout
the night today and that's it you're
ready to use the M and B the operations
there to understand and and clean and
manipulate your data in this context
you can add color which helps guide the
eye too well tables that have a similar
meaning could get the same color I'm not
showing this I really like this one it's
going to assign it here I really like
this one feature we have that that will
check consistency of the relationships
in a data model so if we go through all
the tables to all the relationships and
tell you what look you have a problem
this table along with that table these
are approximately your problems we have
more than seven we did this to not
collect all the problems at once but I
imagine this will be much much greater
thing in the future it's just an example
what what we can do already and what is
available as functionality now once you
have prepared your data model you're
using it it's useful to you it gives
good results coming to your database is
fairly easy we have this copy the m2
verb that will do this for you in this
case I'm copying to a sequel Lite
database in memory same thing that's not
sequel I'd lazy tables and this is what
flatten will do for you so again not for
the
you know more to write this code my hand
maybe also don't want to write this code
with deep-fryer to begin with so this
shows how to create the data on the
Postgres database I'm also not going to
to detail this but maybe one point there
so I see three or maybe four ways to to
deal with mismatches in primary primary
foreign keys so the first way we ignore
them but well and that's what you get
the second way would be to remove rows
that don't match like you just look for
you only keep rows that have matching
row in a related table two more ways
filling the foreign key column with a
null to kind of not not not repair the
relationship but indicate that that
there might be a problem or the fourth
way insert in the in the foreign table
insert synthetic rows that have the
mention primary key bit but are empty
otherwise and this is caught that that
achieves this with with zooming and
zooming maybe we should work more on on
preparing higher-level operations that
are easy to use to clean the data so and
that's about all I wanted to show today
if you're a user it's easy to connect to
database slow to schema or maybe if you
have somebody prepared a function that
creates a DM object for you you can use
it and work with the data presented as a
set of tables and the relationships you
can use it to build relations variable
for your own data
and improve it work with it or use it
for publishing so we did we prepared
data models that we published on sequel
server where it was picked up for my
power bi and we use power bi as a as a
visualization tool for an alert for an
analysis that couldn't be implemented
with power bi alone so we did analysis
and our we copied to power bi the
results used that to visualize and
that's about it for today for me thank
you
I'd be really excited if you could tell
me that
so if it runs TV plier it will probably
run with TM so we're really building on
top of people are db5 herbs that's what
we use and we just for what so in a zoom
table when we do a join before word to
the engine that that's adjoining and if
it works out a lot that that's in in the
ends of the engine so I suspect it might
just work the code that learns the
database schema is currently sequel
server and Postgres only this this
should be adaptable but we're just not
there yet we didn't ever use case if
you're working with another database you
need to connect and then establish
primary foreign key relationships on the
our side manually but this is just one
this is just few lines of code so should
be
do you envision this being a innovation
to which one can do more complex
manipulation and writing to the database
source so updating and inserting records
even how closely this model is beginning
to match full
so with immutable objects we we don't
have any idea of updates or insertions
in the table that's by design in a
project we're using this to build a
process that appends to a database on a
daily basis and we'll see how we can
integrate this in the in the API of DM
so the way I would approach this is to
use the M to prepare whatever you want
to insert as a temporary table and then
emit insert into select star from as a
sequel to show update the table you need
to update but there is currently no
support no built-in support for this
here so you can prepare the data you can
store it in temporary tables and then
from there you really need to walk a few
steps to bring in the data into your
production database
[Music]
yes and no so yes we have code that
splits a table into a parent and child
table so you just like which columns go
to the parent table and that will and it
will use it the unique combinations as a
parent table and linked to the shia to
the child level with a surrogate key
I think I've seen these datasets you're
referring to so we have really thousands
of columns that maybe a panel study or
something I would really go spend a few
days bringing this into a normalized
form where if you have a time series you
have rows instead of columns we have
some tooling for it but it will not just
do it like that you need to do it many
ways but this in the deep layer
framework will save you weeks a month in
the analysis and as opposed to working
with the big white thing
so you can use tables with or data
frames with zero rows that's definitely
supported about loading that's just the
same that that applies we currently
don't have great support for for
appending data or even adding new Neuros
to to a data frame in the DM that's
definitely area for exploration
these are for reading updating
transforming at this time not so much
for depending but I I see the use case
we need to get a feeling for what what's
will be there what's useful operations
here
this is the how do you spell it
how do you spell it
um then your first question please
I'm familiar with sassily so I shot this
flattened operation that would give okay
so this is the flatten that that will do
joints with all the tables that's the
result that's printed to determine all
you see it's a logic theory this means
that this is materialized anywhere it's
like a view except that it's not even a
view on a database the sequel's center
of the database server
it's evaluating the sequel and bringing
this columns in as a return we can take
a look at the sequel underneath using
sequel renderer and basically this is it
so that's sequel code generated for join
or in this case a cascade of joins sent
to the database precept process on a
database results are returned
so yeah so we lazy table is kind of a
view on the on the on the fireside which
defines the operations in drug users
diagram er which is a Swiss Reyes to do
this and all we need to specifies the
names of the optic columns and the
tables and the drawing is automatic
diagram er yes and capital D so let me
see if this works out I have no the
project where I use this a slightly
larger data model takes a second
I can take questions while it's loading
so you can remove tables with select
table and this will also remove the
relationships so in this case I would
create a master DM object and then
create small divisions with table select
the way of focusing on a particular
subset of of the of the thing
okay let's skip that in the demo but we
can go to that we can use all the colors
available in besar and all the hex codes
that we have to color and there is this
TM set color through that takes the
color on left-hand side and the table
veins on the right-hand side when we do
this let's see if this works by getting
the I mentioned type is in blue for a
change so that's it really helps guide
the eye and
I think there is support in the world in
the visualization package for this we
should be looking into that as we move
towards large and larger data models
this this will become an issue so I
think it's related to the the other
question can you can you focus on
subsequently that's what we have but
this is definitely an interesting
extension
okay so the impulsive selected name our
special this would run at the setup
stage when you specify the master data
set you're looking at so in particular
the and filter will be recorded and will
be shown as the filter expressions
whereas when you zoom filter update it's
transparent but how would that feel to
know which table to focus on when we
started with the M filter and zooming
came much later but I still think this
is useful to have special verbs for
column selection and filtering we don't
have the M mutate for example for
mutated zoo mutate update so it's only
filter and select really
currently we don't have code that would
imply Philips a sum for example column
name equality my first question would be
in which direction would the arrows go
probably could argue that the arrows go
from the larger type into the smaller
table and you could use this this as a
heuristic that's that I think that's one
thing we could add because most data
models on the database are really nice
in this way that the call names make
sense and and that there's some some
logic in Hawkins named even if the
primary Florentines
inform his aren't well-defined on the
database we don't have it yet but yeah
it's just one line of code for
relationship - well maybe - you need two
primary key sometimes there's there is
of course space for for extension there
so I think this this falls into the the
second of 30 use cases so you built it
the empyrion data which means splitting
up the table using pivot longer once or
twice and then defining the the keys but
then copying this to database it's just
one step so and and even if you don't
have a database you can work with a
number of data frames and once you copy
to the database it works almost the same
so
I permit like to get this on crown and
in the meantime I think the first and
foremost thing that we don't have yet as
composite keys so that's the reason why
weather is so lonely down there there's
a composite key relationships to the
flights that we cannot process just yet
yeah and then I guess we'll see so the
issue checkers so it's like a Hydra yeah
is someone is just ended three issues
it's really pop up as software projects
tend to be composite keys and maybe
tools for ensuring that your data is
clean and then I think documentation is
a beginning important part so we do have
a page we do have function references we
have an article or two but these need
love this this needs to be maybe
rewritten so that you can really make
sense of it so that's and yeah depending
on what what the user feedback is we can
adjust priorities definitely
right
and I'm sure really so deep fire there
is bind rose that will append data to an
existing table I'm not sure we have a
these things keep dying on me
[Laughter]
we have find rows but we don't have an
absurd equivalent in the pleura and who
don't have this this on DB fire on the
database so I think once these things
get more weight in these packages we
will adapt at the moment this is
something I would solve with
documentation so this is how we go about
did you create a temporary table on your
database and then you emit a c4 let that
ask - it's the data to your database
this
I'm not pushing the button this has
worked well for us but requires so many
effort
[Music]
[Applause]